this Wendover productions video was made
possible by a way get $20 off the
perfect suitcase from away with the code
Wendover at checkout
the post office made America it's an
ambitious claim I know but without it
the United States as we know it today
would not exist as author Winifred
Gallagher eloquently pointed out in her
book how the post office created America
in the years following the American
Revolution one didn't say the United
States is they said the United States
are the country at the time was just a
loose collectivities of states the
national government was weak people
identified with their state first and
their country second with the opening of
the post office however Americans across
the continent had for the first time a
direct link to the federal government
and the outside world in the New England
colonies that preceded the United States
infrastructure was poor it was
considered a great achievement when
travelers could finally reach New York
from Boston in under a week there was
little emphasis on creating roads
between colonies since each was a unique
independent entity some have even
attributed the colonists lack of
attachment to the crown to their lack of
roads those living outside of cities
might have never meant a royal official
in their lives just because of how hard
it was to get around given this the
Crown's postal system in the colonies
was slow expensive and emphasized links
across the Atlantic to Britain almost
more than I did links between the
colonies before the American Revolution
there were unofficial almost
black-market ways of getting mail around
but the increasingly legitimate
Continental Congress the group that
eventually declared American
independence realized that in order to
properly coordinate and collaborate the
member colonists needed a way to
effectively communicate
therefore surprisingly the United States
Post Office was founded almost a full
year before the United States itself in
the century following its founding the
u.s. had a bit of a good problem it
expanded in territory faster than it
could expand in people for much of its
history and still to an extent today the
United States was a country of vast
untamed wilderness this was especially
true in the early year
to the west of the Appalachians despite
the gold rush California only hit a
population of 1 million in about 1890 by
that time the nation had a population of
over 60 million and between California
and the Appalachians during the early
1800s it was hardly anything especially
Rose California might as well have been
an island to get there most people and
mail would take a steamship down to
Panama across the country on land and
then reboard a ship to California rather
than attempting to cross the continent
by land people were naturally afraid to
settle the frontier the idea of being
physically and informational II detached
from the civilized world while
surrounded by untamed and dangerous
wilderness made it difficult for the new
nation to push west you have to remember
that until the telegraph became
widespread in the 1850s and 60s mail was
quite literally the only way to
communicate long distance if you had a
post office you were connected if you
didn't you were alone therefore one of
the first steps for a new town to
legitimize itself was to appeal to the
federal government for a post office and
this was usually granted having a
physical vestige of the federal
government in towns across the continent
was immensely beneficial many would even
say it played a large role in America's
success you see the u.s. today as a
fiercely nationalistic country but as
mentioned for a while
state came before country however these
new brick-and-mortar representations of
the power and benefit of the federal
government helped tie the nation
together but the post offices impact
didn't stop at its mere existence
newspapers shipped free or at least
close to free and that revolutionized
the spread of information in the 1850s
this meant that someone in brand-new
Houston Texas could read a newspaper and
just as easily as someone in Washington
DC if it had been more difficult to
distribute national newspapers
individuals wouldn't have had
information on national politics without
knowledge of national politics the state
might have stayed as the dominant entity
the long overland routes to tiny
frontier towns
solutely did not make money but the post
office wasn't supposed to make money at
the time it was there to make living in
a frontier town of a thousand as similar
as possible to living in an East Coast
town of one hundred thousand one hundred
and fifty years ago it took more than a
month and a half to travel to many parts
of the frontier from New York if you
could get to them at all
however the post offices needed faster
routes so it created post roads long
rudimentary overland routes with time
and traffic however these post roads
developed into America's first
interstate roads the informational links
led to physical links a big question
however was how to efficiently get the
mail out into and across the frontier in
1860 the railroad ended in western
Missouri and after that the mail had to
go out overland the Pony Express was a
short-lived commercial Express mail
service connecting the end of the
railroad to California in only ten days
it could get a letter from the Atlantic
to the Pacific this was unbelievable at
the time when mail arrived at the end of
the railroad line in st. joseph´s
Missouri a writer would take the pouch
of mail and immediately start writing
West at up to 25 miles per hour full
speed and then every ten or so miles
they'd stop at a Pony Express station to
switch to a fresh horse every 75 miles
they'd switch writers to keep the mail
pouch thundering across the country day
and night this didn't come cheap it was
the equivalent of a hundred and thirty
dollars to send just one half ounce
letter but time is money and people did
pay one of the most famous rides of the
short-lived Pony Express was following
the 1860 election Telegraph data exists
at the time but it didn't stretch all
the way across the country the eastern
line ended in Fort Kearney Nebraska so
following the news of Lincoln's win a
writer sat out west using the relay
system writers made their way across the
country to Fort kershel Nevada the
beginning of the Western telegraph line
to transmit the news the West Coast
papers there for publishing news of
Lincoln's win only 7 days and 17 hours
behind the East Coast papers just two
years earlier it took 17 days for news
to cross the continent this was an
unbelievable feat with the completion of
the Transcontinental
Telegraph line in 1861 however the Pony
Express closed its doors after only 19
months of operation but it did play a
big role in the innovation of mail
systems as mail volume rose to the west
coast the u.s. post office looked for
ways to further shorten the travel time
across the continent until the opening
of the Transcontinental Railroad in 1863
most transcontinental mail went out to
Missouri by rail before switching to
lower-cost stagecoach rather than the
Pony Express
at first all westward mail was put on
the train to be sorted in Missouri but
in 1862
the first post office on wheels was put
into operation
a staffer would sort the mail while on
the move in an identical way as a post
office on land so when it arrived in st.
Joseph Missouri it was all split up in
different bundles for different
destinations this system proved
incredibly successful and in the coming
decades the post office gave exorbitant
subsidies and payments to railroads
across the country to move mail most
lines to small communities would never
have been financially viable without the
post office contract stay attractive the
post office therefore was instrumental
in physically connecting small towns
across America to the outside world
expansion was getting easy this role in
innovation happened once again in the
1920s aviation became big during World
War one but once peace was settled it
almost became irrelevant civil aviation
was at first nearly non-existent just
months after the end of World War one
however the first regularly scheduled
air mail route between DC and New York
began by 1925 air mail routes stretched
to hundreds of towns all across the
United States just like with the
railroad the post subsidies allowed for
air service the towns that would never
have been profitable with passenger only
flights the u.s. airmail service grew to
become the largest in the world making
the u.s. one of the most connected
countries in the world and it's legacy
still survives today many of the
airlines that merged into United Delta
and American Airlines were founded as
airmail operators it's easy to forget
that 200 years ago only
eight million people lived in the 20
states and four territories that formed
the Union the continent filled in
incredibly fast and a lot of the credit
has to be given to the postal system few
countries as large as the US have such a
strong national identity the spread of
information is one of the greatest
determinants of a country's success it's
unlikely the US would be such a global
superpower today without the education
connectivity and innovation that the
post-office brought of the five largest
countries in the world the US need only
to not have a serious present-day
sovereignty movement within its borders
this has to be at least partially
attributed to how easy it has always
been to spread information across the
country it may be obsolete today but the
post office was once the peak of
innovation so much so that it made
America this video was made possible by
a way this past weekend I traveled
transatlantic with my new away suitcase
and I can now honestly say it's the
perfect suitcase it's just wonderfully
designed it looks great and has a
built-in tsa approved lock on the top
inside you put bulky stuff on the Left
held in by the mesh and closed on the
right to be compressed by straps it has
a spot for a laptop and even a
waterproof laundry bag to fill up as you
go by far the best feature though has to
be the built in battery to charge your
phone tablet or anything else powered by
USB it can charge your iPhone up to five
times so that you know that you'll
always have a charge when you're on the
go you can get your away suitcase with
$20 off and free shipping within the
contiguous United States by going to
away travel comm slash Wendover and
using the code Wendover at checkout it's
a great way to both support win over
productions and get as I say first-class
luggage at a coach price if you haven't
already please check out my new podcast
called show makers linked here check out
my last video and subscribe to this
channel thanks for watching and I'll see
you again in two weeks for another one /
productions with you
you